do you really enjoy my content but you
literally can't be asked to use your
eyes then you're in luck because you can
now listen to the new random interesting
facts podcast with me 42 available on
youtube spotify apple podcast or
wherever you get your podcast you'll
find a link to it in the description
below
check it out today and give your eyes a
break
you're welcome hey 42 here in late 19th
century america contacting the spirit
world was a lucrative business
seances and paranormal demonstrations
were all the rage with many people
claiming to have unparalleled access to
the afterlife
take the davenport brothers for example
who concocted an elaborate set piece
called the box illusion
which they claimed provided irrefutable
proof of their ability to commune with
the dead
the box illusion went something like
this the brothers would each be tied up
inside a large cabinet along with an
array of musical instruments
after their restraints were examined and
it had been agreed there was absolutely
no way they could free themselves a
curtain was drawn around them
moments later to the astonishment of the
audience the instruments inside the box
would begin to play
once the performance was over the
curtains would be pulled back to reveal
the brothers still tied up apparently
having not moved an inch
now i know that doesn't sound all that
convincing but that's just because
you're a cynical citizen of the 21st
century
back in the mid-19th century plenty of
people believed the brothers had indeed
summoned the dead to come and shake a
tambourine and rattle some maracas for
them
of course in reality the box illusion
was exactly that
an illusion designed to fool the public
and hopefully earn some cash in the
process but not everyone was quite so
easily taken in
a gentleman named eric wise had studied
the box illusion and reached what should
have been the obvious conclusion that
the idea that davenport brothers had
summoned a bunch of ghosts to jam with
them was also
but rather than feel cheated by this
realization
wise was impressed
after all if spirits weren't playing
these instruments that meant that the
davenport brothers were somehow able to
escape their heavy restraints
to make the music themselves
eric would go on to develop his own
elaborate stunts thus included many of
the same restraint defying themes
employed by the davenport brothers only
he never pretended spirits or other
supernatural elements were involved in
doing so he helped give rise to a new
and exciting craze
escapology
[Applause]
oh and by the way whilst i'm guessing
you've probably never heard of eric wise
there's a good chance you're familiar
with his stage name
harry houdini
houdini was born in hungary in 1874
but spent much of his life in america
after his parents emigrated there when
he was four years old
from a young age he dreamt of one day
performing in front of thousands of
people
and he didn't have to wait long for that
dream to come true
making his public debut when he was just
a child he went through a couple of
different stage names in those early
days eric the prince of the air the king
of cards and
the handcuff king before settling on
something a little less boastful
harry houdini after his hero french
magician jean-eugene robert houdin
considering his undisputed legendary
status
it's interesting that houdini's magic
career was met with little enthusiasm to
begin with
he focused on card magic at first but
whilst he was competent enough at card
tricks he was no better than hundreds of
other magicians plying their trade in
america at the time
and if there's one thing harry houdini
never wanted to be
it was average if he was going to do
something he wanted to do it better than
anyone else and so he threw away his
deck of cards and started to perfect a
series of escape acts houdini took his
new show on the road demonstrating his
lock-breaking skills in theaters
exhibitions and even local police
stations and jails i bet that went down
well
despite his best efforts houdini still
failed to drum up the kind of enthusiasm
that he longed for
and by 1898 after years of struggling to
make ends meet he considered quitting
show business for good
fortunately during this moment of
indecision he caught his first big break
when a theater manager gave him a shot
at performing in america's vanderville
house
vanderville shows were hugely popular
variety performances consisting of music
comedy dance and of course magic
houdini was an instant hit and soon
found himself in great demand
riding this wave he soon found himself
touring europe and it was in london that
houdini truly became a global mega star
a british blacksmith had spent five
years designing and building a set of
handcuffs he claimed
no mortal man could escape from and the
daily mirror newspaper challenged
houdini to prove the smith wrong
the much hyped event drew an audience of
4 000 and more importantly for houdini
over a hundred journalists
the crowd gathered at the hippodrome
theatre in london's west end to see if
houdini really was the handcuff king
he'd claimed to be earlier in his career
and after almost an hour of gruelling
mental and physical exertion that
included having to tear off his coat
using a pen knife clasp between his
teeth
houdini was finally able to free himself
the crowd went wild and triumphantly
carried an emotional houdini from the
theater the spectacle made front page
news
and a legend was born
later in life houdini would claim that
this stunt was the most difficult escape
of his career
when simply escaping from handcuffs
became a bit too pedestrian for houdini
he did what most people would do and
started jumping off of bridges into icy
cold rivers whilst being weighed down by
a pile of metal chains and restraints
okay so maybe not most people
on hitting the water houdini would
disappear beneath the surface
for what felt like an eternity and just
when the crowd were beginning to fear
the worst he would reappear free of his
restraint and triumphantly swimming to
the shore
as his fame grew houdini's performances
became even more elaborate he understood
the importance of always remaining one
step ahead of the competition
and he constantly sought to find the
next big trick that would wow his
ever-growing legion of fans
at the hippodrome theater in new york he
made an elephant disappear
in california he almost died after being
shackled and buried alive
and in boston he escaped from the belly
of a sea monster
okay maybe not quite a sea monster most
historians agree the mystery beast from
the murky depths
was actually the carcass of a giant
leatherback turtle that had washed up on
the boston city shoreline
still it was pretty impressive
and a bit gross
for reasons that are very difficult to
understand a group of businessmen had
clubbed together to challenge houdini to
escape from this rotting carcass
if you're doubting whether houdini could
actually have fit inside a turtle
don't
leaverbacks are the largest species of
turtle alive growing up to three meters
in length and weighing in at close to a
metric ton
thousands of people lined the streets as
the turtle carcass was paraded through
the city and carried into a packed
auditorium where houdini awaited its
arrival
with his hands and feet shackled he
crawled inside the belly of the beast
and the entire dead turtle was wrapped
in chains and concealed behind a curtain
after just 15 minutes houdini managed to
free himself emerging
greasy but grinning
according to reports from the time now
it goes without saying but in the
unlikely event that you do have access
to a leatherback turtle carcass
don't try this at home
in order to capitalize on his fame
houdini devised a series of elaborate
stunts that unlike the turtle escape
could be performed night after night on
stage in front of a packed out theater
the first of these was his infamous milk
can escape
which does exactly what it says on the
tin
well can
houdini would submerge himself inside a
giant metal milk can that had been
filled to the brim with water before the
lid was sealed he would encourage the
audience to hold their breath with him
for one minute to help him warm up the
lungs of course the real reason for this
piece of showmanship was to give the
audience an insight into the incredible
physicality of the stunt
most would struggle to reach anywhere
near the minute mark before gasping for
air
making houdini's heroic seem all the
more remarkable
once the lid was sealed under curtain
was drawn around the milk cap houdini
would purposely leave the audience
waiting sometimes for up to an hour
during which time many assumed him dead
but just as attention reached fever
pitch and cries of mercy began to ring
out through the theater houdini would
reappear from behind the curtain
soaking wet and exhausted
but alive
[Music]
of course it would have been impossible
for houdini to hold his breath for the
entire duration of the act the world
record for the longest breath hold
stands at over 24 minutes which is
insane
but well short of an hour especially an
hour of vigorous physical activity
of course much of the apparent danger of
houdini's performances
was all part of the illusion he would
make use of audience misdirection
carefully concealed keys hidden panels
and ingeniously devised fake locks of
his own invention but that's not to say
these performances weren't dangerous at
all
quite the opposite they were brutally
demanding and required houdini to be in
peak mental and physical condition the
man was a bastion of health and fitness
i mean have you seen him he clearly
never skipped leg day
he ate healthily exercised regularly and
never drank alcohol or smoked cigarettes
he taught himself to tie and untie knots
with his feet
and practice special breathing
techniques that enables him to hold his
breath for up to four minutes that might
not sound all that impressive compared
to the world record i just mentioned
but remember this was four minutes of
picking locks and contorting his body
underwater
all of which used up vital oxygen
houdini's dedication to his craft
impacted all aspects of his life
he even refused to sit down whilst
working at his desk believing that it
might cause his body to become stiff and
sluggish
this incredible command over mind and
body
enabled houdini to perform consistently
for almost 30 years
but by the time he reached his 50s
decades of completing these staggering
feats of endurance over and over again
had begun to take their toll
not that houdini was the kind of person
to entertain the idea of taking an early
retirement
instead he began looking for ways to
prolong his ability to perform
and this is where things start to get
really weird
according to a series of letters between
houdini and a close friend
houdini was seriously considering
contacting an acclaimed doctor by the
name of sergey voronov to see if he
could help him out in the small matter
of defying the aging process
now that might not seem too bizarre
after all anyone wanting to increase
their life expectancy could do much
worse than asking a doctor for advice
but varunov specialized in a field that
was
a little more extreme than most
you see he believed the secret to
eternal youth could be found in
chimpanzee testicles
yeah
in case you're wondering how this worked
the procedure involves sewing a small
amount of chimp testicle tissue into the
patient's
scrotum wow there's a sentence i never
thought i'd hear myself saying
anyway
varanov claims this genuinely insane
operation would grant the patient some
kind of monkey-based superpowers
including
an increased sex drive the ability to
work longer hours
improved eyesight and better memory
recall
all of this sounded right up houdini
street and whilst we don't know if he
ever underwent the procedure
some houdini researchers believe he
might just have
unfortunately it would soon transpire
that with or without the help of
chimpanzee balls
death was an inevitability
even the mighty houdini was unable to
escape from
although in true houdini style he wasn't
going to go out conventionally
like much of his life even houdini's
death is shrouded in mystery and
intrigue
though the official cause of death is a
ruptured appendix
it's a bizarre incident that took place
in his dressing room shortly beforehand
that really captured the headlines
[Music]
whilst performing his famous water
torture escape at the albany in new york
a trick that required houdini to be hung
upside down by his ankles while
submerged in a tank of water he suffered
a broken ankle after part of the
mechanism malfunctioned
being the superhuman that he was houdini
continued performing regardless but a
few days later he was resting the
swirling ankle in the comfort of his
dressing room when he was approached by
a medical student named jocelyn
whitehead
whitehead asked houdini if it was true
that punches to the stomach didn't hurt
him
houdini casually replied with something
along the lines of yeah i'm well hard
but whitehead wanted proof and without
warning set about punching houdini in
his stomach as hard as he could over and
over again
unprepared and lying prone thanks to his
broken ankle houdini crumpled in pain
before whitehead perhaps realizing he
should have just asked for an autograph
ceased his flurry of blows
it's impossible to know for sure whether
or not houdini was already suffering
from appendicitis before this incident
but he certainly was afterwards
amazingly he continued to perform
despite the broken ankle inflamed
appendix and a 104 degree temperature
it's even said that at one point during
his final performance he passed out
but continued the show after being
revived
think about that the next time you call
in sick with man flu after two days of
agony houdini admitted defeat and was
taken to the hospital where he had his
ruptured appendix removed
unfortunately his refusal to seek
medical attention earlier cost him his
life and he died on halloween 1926 with
his wife bess at his bedside was even
after his death houdini's myth continued
to grow
an urban legend that he had died whilst
performing his death-defying water
torture trick began to circulate but it
turned out that was just invented by a
50s hollywood film director who decided
a punch in the gut wasn't a cinematic
enough way for the great houdini to die
some have speculated that houdini's
appendicitis was caused by dr voronov's
controversial procedure
but the most prominent rumor surrounding
his death is that he was poisoned by
spiritualists
angry at his open rejection of their
beliefs
houdini had spent years debunking
paranormal demonstrators like the
davenport brothers with their box
illusion
he even offered ten thousand dollars to
anyone who could present evidence of the
spirit world
that he was unable to explain
a hefty wager that needless to say he
never had to pay out on
despite being such a prominent
paranormal skeptic
it does seem that houdini wasn't 100
convinced because he made a pact with
his wife that after his death he would
try to contact her from beyond the grave
even going so far as to give her a
secret code so she'd know it was really
him
but after a decade of attempting to
contact her late husband for a series of
seances
bess houdini finally gave up all hope of
receiving a message from the afterlife
still an official houdini seance is held
to this day on halloween every year
perhaps houdini's greatest trick was
that he understood the power of his own
mythology
he never revealed the secrets behind his
escapes refusing to patent any of the
stunts for fear of breaking the
illusions he'd so skillfully crafted he
was a master of generating hype
establishing a close relationship with
the press at a time when celebrity was
still in its infancy
he was known to perform elaborate
straight jacket escapes right outside of
press office windows making it
impossible for them to not put him on
the front pages he never missed an
opportunity to promote himself in new
and innovative ways if he heard about a
new brewery opening in town he'd contact
them and arrange to escape from one of
their beer kegs promoting both himself
and the brand of beer in the process
these days celebrity endorsements and
cozying up to the media are both
essential steps when trying to generate
global hype but during houdini's
lifetime his methods were groundbreaking
in all aspects of his career houdini was
years ahead of his time
constantly evolving his performances
perfecting his craft and masterfully
promoting himself
in order to ensure that houdini mania
swept across the globe
and i guess it worked
today he is very probably the most
famous magician
ever to have lived
thank you for watching